the hyperloop is the world's most epic
transportation system it's a
magnetically levitating train in a
vacuum tube with a maximum speed of 1200
kilometers per hour this idea from 1888
was first conceived by Elon Musk in 2012
but he said
thus the hyperloop was born and
immediately after the best and the
brightest pounced on the concept aiming
to revolutionize Transit it's been 11
years since musk's faithful speech he
himself did not get involved in
development and he couldn't now even if
he wanted to as his tube is a signal
boosting 4 at lunatics on Twitter while
at the same time running the sight into
the ground only true Geniuses can
multitask like that but thankfully as I
said musk wasn't the only one who saw
promising the hyperloop people just as
smart and talented as musk also jumped
on the bandwagon and before we knew it a
whole plethora of companies were
competing to change Transportation
forever we've been waiting 11 years for
a functional hyperloop system and we're
still waiting but what are all those
hyperloop companies up to nowadays where
are they now first off arivo arrivo is a
hyperloop company founded by Brogan
bambogram yeah that's his real name who
apparently kept an ax in his office with
which he would punch a hole in the wall
to that of steam now there is a sign to
be successful well-run company though
our evil started as a hyperloop company
the vacuum tube idea was quickly
abandoned in favor of maglev technology
you know that thing which doesn't exist
yet and definitely needs pioneering so
Ben Rogan was like What if maglev but
worse
and so these magnetic courselets were
dreamed up which were supposed to fix
congestion because as we all know adding
more capacity to Rose definitely won't
motivate more people to get in their
cars thereby making congestion worse gee
I wonder if this is a well-known
phenomenon we've been aware of since
like 1930 because if that was the case
that would make a Revo and Brogan look
real silly though thankfully
unfortunately are evil went bankrupt a
year later ultimately forcing them to
departo next up hyperloop delft oh I've
been to delft it's a beautiful small
college town in the Netherlands and now
they're also building a hyperloop
founded in 2016 after seven years of
feverish development they have a tiny
proof of concept model ah yes the
Amsterdam Paris High pillar which is
most definitely needed if only there was
a fast and convenient Transit link
between these two cities already look I
don't want to give them too much
they are a non-profit and this is
clearly just a university project
students come and go every year and they
get some useful hands-on experience
working on their prototype nothing will
ever come a bit sure but this is first
and foremost an educational tool plus
the whole worked on the hyperlue bullet
point will look good on their CV is the
recruiters who haven't watched my videos
moving on we have hyperloop Italia what
is this website oh it's one of those
scrolling things all right uh let's
let's watch the video oh that's nice
okay so their videos seem to have been
deleted that's cool uh wait these are
just hyperloop TT promotional images you
know they must be their Italian
subsidiary then wait who is this guy is
he crying sir blink once if you're being
held against your will
since this is a subsidiary let's look at
the origin Point instead hyperloop TT
the TT part meaning Transportation
Technologies they have a helpful section
on their website exploring their
progress so far okay so in 2013 they
were just starting out 2014 the same
2015 missing oh 2016 was a busy year
they seem to have invented mag Labs
right they just built a small scale
prototype we're revealing vibranium skin
material wow for those of you who don't
know vibranium is just a carbon fiber
tube with some sensors in it it's a name
Elon came up with to appeal to sci-fi
oriented young adults who are bad at
interpreting social cues wow what's this
Bruno Czech Republic takes first step to
create European hyperloop connecting to
Slovakia ah yes Bruno the city that
legalized parking on the sidewalk and
that refused to help Ukrainian refugees
who were over my ethnicity left them out
on the streets and then tried to house
The Amity Detention Facility truly a
place of progress and Innovation back to
the list in 2017 it's more photo ops and
PR stuff 2018 wow hyperloop TT announces
partners and construction start for
commercial system in Abu Dhabi it's
happening folks well through the power
of me reading this in 2023 I can tell
you that absolutely nothing came of this
project oh I know this one this is the
hyperport the cargo hyperloop from the
port of Hamburg into the continent
because after a container spends four
weeks on a cargo ship it cannot sit on a
train for three more days it has to
barrel down a hundred billion Euro
vacuum tube because that's how Logistics
works also European commission moves
ahead in assessing hypo regulatory needs
alright you might notice a lot of these
articles are either just fluff pieces
order about some institutions starting a
process to organize the meeting where
they will discuss what food should be
served on the Gathering where they
schedule the zoom call to confirm the
session where 0.86-9 F of the agenda
will be about what should we do with
this hyperloop thing these mean nothing
yet the hyperloop TT people put them out
on their website nonetheless if you ever
had to pair out an essay at school this
might feel familiar to you from 2019
till 2022 it's much the same feasibility
studies Corporation agreements that lead
nowhere apparently they also released a
bunch of hyperloop nfts and because of
course they have their most recent news
item is from 6 months ago but the under
veiling of the second four scale
capsuletic convention curiously photos
are missing from this article aside from
the headline image but I went to Twitter
and found four more thankfully now you
might think this is extremely
embarrassing a three decade of work all
they have is a static mock-up of the
capsule that people can sit in except
that's not the capsu's interior that's a
2d canvas print stretched over the
gaping hole of their empty tube after a
decade of work this is all they have a
hollow tube with some studio lights
slapped inside wires and all with two
monitors that don't even match playing
videos on Loop and open intended next to
the miniature mock-ups of their Interior
Furniture this is what they accomplished
in a decade Ukrainian Engineers are out
there changing Modern Warfare with
Hardware they invented and built from
scratch in a year during an active war
and are mass producing it out of a shed
meanwhile these morons couldn't
accomplish more than a carbon fiber
sewer pipe after a decade finally we
have hyperloop 1 formerly virgin
hyperloop formerly version hyperloop one
formerly hyperloop one formerly
hyperloop Technologies if one company is
going to make the hyperloop real then
this is it while other companies were
just a loose collection of consultants
and idea guys barreling towards
bankruptcy hyperloop one means business
they have funding real professionals and
an actual working prototype with humans
in it an actual working pod which my
friend thunderhood suspects to be a
piece of jet fuselage encased in plastic
and I tend to agree they even perform
the successful test run following that
virgin perhaps realized that this is an
extremely dangerous impractical and
stupid idea so they pulled out of the
project and that hyperloop one announced
they would focus on freight instead and
started laying off employees at Mass
their website is now an empty void with
a new site coming soon message with a
faint render of the cargo hyperlue
capsule almost rotating in the back and
I for one can't wait to see the actual
renders of this epic project that won't
happen in a million years due to being a
fundamentally stupid and impractical
idea so after a decade of work all these
much hyped hyperloop companies have
basically nothing to show for it tiny
models empty mock-ups scrapped
prototypes and dissolved companies and
this is not because the evil fossil fuel
or train Lobby is trying to sabotage
them rather because the hyperloop or
your passenger is just an incredibly
stupid and impractical idea where all
you need is one crazy person blowing up
one section of one tube somewhere and
the resulting vacuum failure plus the
wall of one atmosphere air rushing in
will immediately turn hundreds of people
into canned spaghetti
thank you
this is assuming they can even maintain
such an enormous vacuum chamber deal
with the problem of heat expansion
tectonic activity extreme weather and so
on after managing to somehow purchase
all the land needed across multiple
countries in a straight line to be able
to even potentially start construction
seriously all technical impossibilities
any practicalities aside try drawing a
straight line between two large cities
and see how many villages cities lakes
rivers national parks and so on or in
your way places where you cannot build
but can't go around because your 1200
kilometers per hour pods cannot do sharp
turns and would need it almost
completely straight line once again this
is just a land acquisition we haven't
even talked about all the technical
issues which make this whole project
impossible if you want to know more
about those I have a video about it you
can check out Link in the description
having reached the end of this train
wreck no pun intended allow me to
present the cherry on top in the book
titled Elon Musk written by cultist
Ashley Vance on page 470 you will find
the following musk had been thinking
about the hyperlooperate number of
months describing it to friends in
private the first time he talked about
it to anyone outside his inner circle
was during one of our interviews musk
told me that the idea originated out of
his hatred for California's proposed
high-speed rail system he insisted the
hyperloopod cost about 6 to 10 billion
go faster than a plane and let people
drive their cars onto a pod and drive
them into a new city at the time it
seemed that musk dished out the
hyperloop proposal to make the public
and legislators rethink the high speed
train he didn't actually intend to build
the thing with any luck the high-speed
rail would be canceled musk said as much
to me during a series of emails and
phone calls leading up to the
announcement down the road I might
Thunder advise a hyperloop project but
right now I can't take my eye off the
ball at either SpaceX or Tesla he wrote
what you just listened to was a direct
admission that the whole hyperloop
project was pure from the start
a cynical scheme devised by musk to try
to sabotage California's High-Speed Rail
Project to preserve the dominance of the
core thankfully he was about as
successful with it as with running
Twitter but the sad part is this scam
has managed to Kickstart a decade-long
effort by people of lower than average
social literacy to try and make their
God's Vision become a reality it's a sad
sight to behold but honestly did we
really expect anything more than that
and this this is the state of the
hyperloop in 2023 or was rather we can
all agree that this thing just isn't
happening anymore too many people
wiseened up and the California high
speed rail is actually getting built so
the hyperloop concept has lost whatever
little viability it had left some
dictatorship might still take a crack at
it like the Saudis when they're on busy
gunning down Africans on their border
But ultimately I think we can pronounce
this project dead and I thank you for
watching don't forget to like And
subscribe and I'll be seeing you next
time
[Music]
foreign